added about 11 o'clock her rebel came
running into the cab we heard this
incredible eruption people started
shooting at us and fire coming from all
directions bullets were flying all over
the place it was just around us I
grabbed and tried to take shelter we
were trying to get away from the bullets
it was total chaos in the camp rebels
were running in all directions not
knowing exactly where the shooting was
coming from and they was a rebel and
I think he was trying to escape with us
but they were just shooting everywhere
one guy was determined to to really
protect us he was and as we were running
we could hear the bullets did we hear
the bullets we could see the bullets
ripping through the news and then it got
quiet
the military took out the second weapon
you hear it when they shoot it it makes
us buh sound 805 mul ground to e missile
and then you hear it when it comes in
because it whistles and then the first
thing exploded and they were literally
just shelling it in the middle of the
camp
you just year that it was shadow and
tremble as they explode next to you you
can run away who uses her to sing come
and it was coming and coming
we putting it away anyway we were
tricked
I fell on top of money
and I really realized that today might
be our very last day and Kali turned to
me and said to me you have to make peace
we might die today
I still remember saying to Kali after I
said I don't want to die here today I
said to him I still want a baby
it was really the first time that I
really meant it
the fact that she made that step yeah I
just just just meant the world to me
it is sort of myself I've done so many
great things I've had so many adventures
and I've seen the world but that was the
one thing I haven't done yet we really
surrendered our life and our situation
to you God